obi-wan trailer here we go the fight is
done
the fight is done
we lost
[Music]
he's watching oh
[Music]
the key
to hunting jedi
to this patience
jedi cannot help what they are
their compassion
[Music]
leaves a trail
the jedi code is like an itch
he cannot help it
where is he
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's cool
that's cool how they did that logo
dang
that was pretty dang good i'm really
excited for that i was definitely such a
teaser a little teary-eyed there just
because i love star wars so much
um yeah this is gonna be show that i'm
gonna be covering so for the star wars
fans out there i hope you'll be watching
it with me uh this looks like a show
that is really gonna be pretty freaking
awesome
um if it's gonna be anything like the
indiana book of boba fett and the
mandalorian i think we're in for a
pretty big treat here especially with it
with mcgregor and hayden christensen
coming back as darth vader slash anakin
skywalker i think this this is gonna be
a pretty awesome show but let me know
what you think of the very first trailer
for it in the comments down below don't
forget to subscribe and as always i'll
see you guys next time woof